Me entrenaron para convertirme en gimnasta
durante dos años en Hunan, China, en los años 70'.
Cuando estaba en primer grado, el gobierno
quería transferirme a una escuela para atletas
con todos los gastos pagos.
Pero mi madre tigre dijo, "No".
Mis padres querían que me convirtiera
en ingeniera, como ellos.
Luego de sobrevivir la Revolución Cultural,
creían firmemente que había solo un camino certero hacia la felicidad:
un trabajo seguro y bien remunerado.
Sin importar si el trabajo me gustara o no.
Pero mi sueño era ser una cantante de ópera china.
Esta era yo, en mi piano imaginario.
Una cantante de ópera debe comenzar a entrenarse desde muy joven
para aprender las acrobacias,
así que intenté todo lo que pude para ir a la escuela de ópera.
Hasta le escribí al director de la escuela
y al presentador de un programa de radio.
Pero a ningún adulto le agradaba la idea.
Ningún adulto me tomó en serio.
Solo mis amigos me apoyaban, pero eran niños,
sin autoridad, como yo.
Así fue que a la edad de 15 años, sabía que ya era demasiado mayor para entrenar.
Mi sueño nunca se realizaría.
Temía, que durante el resto de mi vida
una felicidad de segunda clase
fuese lo único a lo que podría aspirar.
Y esto era tan injusto.
Así que resolví buscar otra vocación.
¿Nadie a mi alrededor quería enseñarme? Bien.
Recurrí a los libros.
Sacié mi sed por el consejo de mis padres
con este libro por una familia de escritores y músicos ["Correspondencia en la Familia de Fou Lei"]
Encontré mi modelo a seguir en una mujer independiente
cuando la tradición del confucianismo requiere obediencia. ["Jane Eyre"]
Y aprendí a ser eficaz de este libro. ["Más barato por docena"]
Y después de leer estos libros me inspiré para estudiar en el exterior.
["Obras Completas" de Sanmao (alias Echo Chan)] ["Lecciones de la Historia" de Nan Huaijin]
Llegué a EE.UU. en 1995,
y ¿cuáles fueron los primeros libros que leí aquí?
Los que estaban prohibidos en China, por supuesto.
"La Buena Tierra" trata de la vida campesina china.
Y no es propaganda conveniente. Entendido.
La Biblia es interesante, pero extraña.
(Risas)
Ese es un tema para otro día.
Pero el quinto mandamiento para mí fue una revelación:
"Honrarás a tu padre y a tu madre".
"Honrar", me dije. "Es tan diferente,
y mucho mejor que obedecer".
Así que se convirtió en mi herramienta para salir
de esta trampa de culpa confuciana
y para reiniciar la relación con mis padres.
El encuentro con una nueva cultura también dio lugar a mi hábito
de lectura comparativa.
Brinda muchas perspectivas.
Por ejemplo, al principio este mapa me pareció fuera de lugar
porque esto es lo que los alumnos en China aprendían.
Jamás se me había ocurrido,
que China no tenía que estar en el centro del mundo.
Un mapa implica la perspectiva de las personas.
La lectura comparativa no es algo nuevo.
Es una práctica común en el mundo académico.
Hay hasta campos de investigación
como religión comparativa y literatura comparativa.
Comparar y contrastar, le ofrece a los académicos
un entendimiento más profundo de un tema.
Y pensé que si la lectura comparativa
funcionaba para investigar, ¿por qué no hacerlo también en la vida cotidiana?
Así fue que comencé a leer libros de a dos.
Pueden tratarse de personas